[Music]
Snowdonia and the Dewey formerly on
earth constituency and whereas our
former PM David Cameron's Celtic Kingdom
of choice was Cornwall the incumbent
prefers these verdant clients holidaying
here in the town of Dahl Hecky only last
Easter where she made a rather important
decision that you may or may not be
aware but the Prime Minister is a very
keen Walker she said that walking gives
her clarity so much so that the last
time she was in this town
she decided whilst on a walk to call an
early general election I don't know
about you but I don't feel that this
campaign has exactly had a lot of
clarity in it so far so what better to
do then recreate that walk and see if we
can shed some light but I just kind of
feel I'm not quite in the right gear
much better
the BM has her eye on a clutch of Welsh
seats and the toys are second here but
it's a Clyde stronghold so is there any
chance of their taking it before I find
out I need a guidebook the same she used
I'm told from this very shop it's one
thing sir thank rhyme ministers book
yeah 495 please she purchased a book
from us a few months back it was the end
of last year which he gave to Angela
Merkel Oh
another strong and stable figure all set
now to actually find some voters I still
don't really feel like I should call
them early general election there are
about as many voters on this walkers at
the average Teresa made campaign event
are you latverian you vary in Tory but
no matter I have a hot lead the PM
apparently bought some jewelry when she
was last year maybe if I buy that I can
finally get into the mind of May's the
earrings that have been here at the
moment was similar to the ones and one
of the rings she boards tighter we're
not buying the set is it I know so do
the tourists and the chance here the bed
for Parliament at the moment this
constituency is my Welsh teacher oh well
there you go
well we have always known our mp3 player
Murray like uh Murray definitely I
applied yes yeah only she doesn't walk
very far well perhaps not just yet but
either way that PM got her clarity and
we got an election as a result she's
riding quite a way if it did carry her
through this Clyde heartland she might
just choose to holiday
Lewis good ol sky news